I am here with one of the best
snowboarders in the world canna Teeter
Teeter tear teeter-totter
my teeter totter yep Harry Potter can I
call you Harry Potter if we get closer
as friends right okay
Shazam we just cast the friendship spell
every snowboarded before no I don't want
to be bound to oh you know oblong disk
it's kind of the coolest sport because
everyone's really cool it's a cool sport
and it's kind of like skateboarding and
surfing what's your cool things yeah
skiing is like what being strapped to
boards like two foot boards I feel like
the skiers are a little bit cocky too
yeah what's with their saving attitude
so cool yeah but really but right they
want to be snowboarders but they're
stuck on skis of course they do
they're always mashing them together
wishing they'd merge into one yeah do
you feel a lot of pressure to not eat
cupcakes I do I'm very strict with my
diet but can't you because you burn so
many calories you can eat whatever you
want right yeah you can but I mean I
just steer clear cuz I don't want to go
down that path once you start with that
it's a gateway dessert it is really
leads to many other things
devil food cake friggin pudding pudding
as a beverage ah you ever get to that
point uh that was my rock bottom
drinking pudding mm-hmm
somebody told me that you run a charity
I'm to charities - yeah sorry Hannah's
goal calm and as gold
Hannah's goal and I sell I grew up
making maple syrup so I sell maple syrup
to sponsor town in Africa and then I
also have sweet cheeks panties and we
sell underwear sorry sweet cheeks
sweet cheeks panic yep and we sell
underwear to sponsor the game on program
children internationals game on program
where it's like an all-in-one inclusive
facility for third-world country kids so
they have school and sports and
nutrition food like everything all in
one all frumpy is all from selling
panties are you I am panties panties
panties maple syrup and panties there's
a great combination there's one weird
guy in Germany that's like my two
favorite charities I get all of my sex
me it's
same place I do want to thank you for
being here thanks for having me what do
we do
I don't know you go that you can do that
and these yeah little bump little flavor
that means we're tight